the time has finally come the pewdiepie
you really collab is out
six bros versus one secret pewdiepie i
am so excited
to finally watch this
[Music]
december 1st they posted yeah
all right let's skip the interim six
bros versus one secret pewdiepie
that's kind of fudge yeah we reached out
to pewdiepie
they did i for the record i reached out
to you
but they didn't see my email i don't
know how
but we made it work regardless because
we both wanted it to happen and this is
what happened
let's go
we brought together six pewdiepie fans
also
yeah also the most attractive
best looking most intelligent
people on the planet i am a bro
i am a bro i am a bro i am a bro i
am a bro i am a bro technically you're a
19 year old but
i understand it's a secret pewdiepie i
am
bearded if the group discovers who
pewdiepie is
they'll win a cash prize if pewdiepie
survives
he wins the cash prize
get that money the bros vote out the
real pewdiepie no way
this no way they came no spoilers
all right the game played i don't have a
plan
i'm screwed to be honest i didn't
understand what we were doing though
i should have come in with a better game
plan yes maybe i shouldn't
but i didn't okay a game plan is to just
honestly look for what the most
stereotypical pewdiepie
fan would be that's pretty smart
actually because that was basically my
plane
dna i am from croydon in uk i watched
pewdiepie since i was 16.
i watched his amnesia let's plays
that's usually what i hear people say
whenever they're send me a message
they're like i watch you since i was
blah blah blah
amnesia true and i went for the most
stereotypical damning
wait did he think i was going to get
voted out on the first i honestly the
future might get voted out of the first
round i'm not gonna lie
we're gonna no way i'm getting voted out
on the first one get out of here yeah
pewdiepie
like let's be honest here i know he's a
bad liar maybe that clip
hey you're absolutely right
it's like a weird game of among us we'll
see how this goes
nice
okay a little bit of background here or
maybe i'll show i'll share it later
but yeah we were all talking in the chat
obviously we only had the avatars
i didn't create my avatar which i think
was a mistake
and i also didn't pick my name which i
think was a mistake
and i didn't think about the location i
was like
yeah i guess i know london a little bit
uh pick london uh
sweden is too obvious but i should have
picked sweden because it is too obvious
i didn't get to do the big breaks right
okay but anyway
yo greetings everyone so
i'm like yo and tyler look at that hey
guys i'm brendan
the only thing alex has said so far i
was a little suspicious of i just said
yo
i was that suspicious what was i
supposed to say
kp said yo too
tyler mind reader okay where's the gun
emoji that's not vegan
i wanted to type like oh if you know hey
if you're pewdiepie named amber
pewdiepie video that's what i wanted to
do tonight
if you're pewdiepie name every video he
made
if you're pewdiepie named every video
he's made
we got the states india we got vegas i'm
from london
i'm in check it's from jacksepticeye
yeah it was funny they were all funny
i'm from london
damn it why did you say i was from
what i don't know any places greenland
alex says he's from london
london alex is looking suspicious damn
it
i'm so timmy by the way because future's
always like a little timmy whenever
[Laughter]
see i knew i had to keep kp as an ally
because he was sussing to me
we have to get timmy out it's true he
does
come on little timmy what's happening
surprisingly
it is they know more about pewdiepie
than i do go to
he's not very creative is that too much
of a giveaway
it was it was yeah i'm glad i didn't
write that
he looks like fat
good point but i'm thinking alice
because he looks like fat i like that
beauty
why that's so mean it does look like
me there it is correct
brendan going out alex jeez what if that
wasn't
no what the hell dude
got a point and then i'm like well
brendan looks most like
pewdiepie though huh london voice us
i'll happily be fat pewdiepie okay
they're not dead on uh help me get over
a breakup in 2017. oh friend babe
okay i trust brendan dammit
he snuck in with a good lineup brendan
seems legit to be
so cool
so cool so cool
you know when you type something and you
immediately as you hit enter
like that is not how i wanted to say
that
brendan seemed legit to be cause
everyone was like oh that's so nice
that's like so cool
you're right how do you do it shut up
shut up
i'm 90 sure it's alex hey bro fist of
the chat
i'll give you bro fist alex as i vote
you out damn you brendan
oh my god i'm a little bit nervous now
i'm trying to distract them with a
broken
legit it's so weird being in a jubilee
video
excuse me jubilee what do you mean it's
so weird being in a you
you believe you billy jubilee jubilee
that makes no sense get out of here
jubilee
jupiter jupiter it's not humble when i
called alex out i called him fat
pewdiepie which alex if you're not
pewdiepie i'm so sorry
okay i'm glad he addressed that as he
said was cassidy suss to me
so cassidy you're out i think i'll vote
for cassidy because
see i was right can't be my bro real bro
right there
that's the only thing of suspicion i
really have i am gonna vote off
nikki because i had a bad feeling about
her right off the start right now i'm
kind of suspicious
damn it why nikki damn it you could have
saved me
the lmao and him saying yo i'm gonna
i said yo what am i not allowed to say
y'all
you're a goddamn psychic tyler yo
i'm gonna vote alex i'm gonna vote off
alex because i think other people are
voting alex
i don't know why pewdiepie would say
that he was from london because i would
immediately like
i don't know i'm gonna vote for alex but
you voted me anyway
nikki the votes are in for round one
and the person eliminated this round is
look at me there's still hope i was like
damn this would really suck if i get
voted out in the first round i really
don't want to get forwarded out in the
first round
[Laughter]
alex
[Music]
[Laughter]
maybe picking london was too obvious i
should have gone to la or something well
done
okay now i can explain so i thought for
sure
i had thrown the whole competition right
away i was so
confident that it was over before i even
said
anything because when they asked
everyone to type
ready before we start recording they
would ask us to type
ready so he was like timmy type ready
tyler type
ready nicky type ready and then he was
like alex type ready and i'm over here
like
alex and then he goes again like alex
type ready
oh ready
alex that's me of course so i thought
that was a dead giveaway
and i thought for sure they would pick
up on that but no one just seemed to
discuss
it so i'm just bad at lying about
clearly terrible at lying
but the gamers go on they don't know
that they're
gonna get played out now sex location
what youtubers do you watch other than
pewds
that should be none yes i laugh at my
own jokes thank you
city i'm lowkey sauce of you why didn't
they vote on cassidy then
who said that who said cassidy i'm sort
of you nikki
nikki you wanted you could have gone to
cassidy we couldn't get a cassidy
why didn't they vote on cassidy then
cassidy's 22 female missouri no way
pewdiepie has any idea what missouri is
brendan you sure you got their mouth all
right i know
it's in the center of america
somewhat thank you very much brandon has
no chelsea you believe in you i like the
mvc minecraft
my favorite series is three free games
bring it back i've never heard anyone
say that
yeah it's funny seeing like very
individual opinions about stuff
it's also really fun seeing my audience
super dope
american spell color color
what a good i would say with an oh you i
don't know if
that would be a giveaway that's a great
question
oh i think cassidy is safe i think pewds
spell color like the european way
are any of you in the pewdiepie discord
not generally
i just talked to friends on there
they're not on my discord what is this
cassidy is a mod there and created the
banner for the prophetic for the server
that's awesome by the way or are you
the admin i like how they're all just
vibing
they're like yeah what they're not yeah
exactly they're not even voting anyone
out they're like oh yeah this is cool we
got them
they went from cassidy to nikki
nikki going down hard on me but i get it
nikki counter with the most
strong argument you can make it's not me
that's really the only thing i've said
in there i like this guy three pieces
i think we're not pewds i think we're
not pewds that's enough for me i guess
it's not cassidy
cassidy says i know it ain't timmy
because peter doesn't have an iphone
these guys are playing 40 chests over
here like damn
how do they even know i don't because we
use this uh phone
service to chat right damn cassidy well
playing i faced my entire strategy
in round one it was alex and we had to
get him out and now that he's out
i have no idea what to do i'm still
gonna go with brendan because he really
didn't put a lot of input
in this round so nikki i'm sorry but
i think you're gonna have to go gosh i
guess i'm okay so
i was really really really hoping they
would just vote someone out at this
point which i know make
doesn't make sense because that means
that person doesn't get any money
but i just didn't want to look bad okay
the votes are in
and we have a tie no oh we have a tie
the tie is between nikki and brendan
brendan oh
man nikki and brendan that means we're
going to tie breaker
each person will get to state one reason
saying why they like pewdiepie
this is a nice eco boost okay so
pewdiepie
is the perfect mix of not taking
yourself too seriously while still
knowing how to tackle life with
self-respect that's why i really like
them
brendan give brendan money
[Music]
yeah brady you're all right yeah all
right because that's actually true
growing up girls couldn't play games in
my house so watching ps was the only way
i could participate in gaming moment oh
what i should have typed so cool
that's really nice that's so cool to
hear these stories
that's a really really good reason give
nicki minaj can't be gamers
everyone knows this keep gaming nikki i
think brendan is toast
oh no i don't feel like any of them are
pewds maybe he's doing big brain strats
and actually going for like a different
gender in a different race
the votes are in for the tiebreaker and
the person i can't do that tyler
i'm pretty sure certain people would
have a field day if i did that and
eliminated this round
is nikki
hey they wrote a nicky yeah i thought
for sure they were voting
sweet answer how could you brendan's out
you're done
you're done brendan how dare you call me
fat pewdiepie
i guess i don't have much to say this is
a fun video to watch i found pierce when
i was going through a breakup since then
he's made me laugh and think differently
almost on a weekly basis brendan give
brendan money
come on they think that's us
i'm from ohio that's where i'm from
i feel like it could be tyler because i
feel like pewds would say eleanor
a lot not gonna lie he's right i would
say that a lot
they're getting into see they know all
this stuff i'm super impressed
now i specifically remember being at
like a dance duty when i was like
seven and seeing appears to be back when
he had duck profile picture the dance
studio introduced you to pewdiepie
sticking to the story tyler only 14.
i think it's tyler get him out
why did i say that makes no sense for me
to say
what the [ __ ] it's tyler
am i forgotten what i'm doing
i don't know i have no idea i have no
clue
it's funny seeing them interact it feels
like i'm not supposed to see this almost
i really guess kp that's really all i
can think of
i think i might go with red because the
breakup thing
i mean you could definitely make that up
i think i'm going to vote for brendan
i'm going to vote for tyler it's got to
be
i knew brendan was out pewdiepie would
try to pretend he was a young kid that
would be kind of weird
i still think it's better the votes are
in for round three and the person
eliminated this brendan knows
brendan i knew it yeah oh my god
i knew it was coming i should have been
a little bit more
personable in the chat if everyone feels
confident that you already voted out
pewdiepie you can
end the game now if the majority has
doubt
the game will continue they're going to
end the game for sure
i think we got him i think we should
everything yeah we've got to vote one
more time there's no one else suspicious
we went another round i would get
eliminated majority has voted
no we will end the game oh my god no
guys
i'm sorry nikki i'm sorry brendan
if the color that shows up is green you
all win if it's red pewdiepie is still
in the game and you all lost whatever
happens i'm happy i made it to the end
in three two
[Applause]
well
one
the game is over and the bros have won
now the moment of truth
let's find out who is pewdiepie please
turn on your cameras in three
two one
this is the moment where i have to
reveal myself and be awkward in front of
people here we go
it's fat pewdiepie
[Applause]
okay props to the editor here to make
sense out of everyone yelling because
when it was happening it was completely
incoherent everyone was losing it it was
so
funny
[Applause]
was so stereotypical on the headphones
and the phone i didn't make that big
emoji
honestly also props to tyler for getting
it literally straight away
i genuinely cannot believe this right
now i'm not surprised you guys got it to
be honest so well done to everyone
sorry there was a few casualties on the
way oh you had fun as well
last question for you pewdiepie if you
were to call out another celebrity or
influencer to be part of odd man out who
would it be
um mr beast
i don't know why i said mr beast i
wanted to say jack but i was also like i
don't know if i want to put jack on the
spot
he is my favorite youtuber and he has
inspired me so
much cassidy was so sweet also we're in
the merch i see you cassidy
very nice i wonder how i inspired him
i'd love to hear more brennan super
funny biggest takeaway from this
experience it's just that we have such a
great community you know the nine year
olds the 19 year olds
called the pro army yeah this is like
the most wholesome jubilee video i've
ever watched everyone is always
i mean they grab random people right so
it's obvious and
competing for money but this is just
wholesome like people just wanted to
play for the fun of it
and everyone was just so nice except
brendan of course be
humble i think i think that's one of
pewdiepie's most shining quality
being a bro means family
brofist shout out to period seven please
include that
editors that's cool editor we're back
with the new season of and they're back
one now
yes what is the makeup artist off the
top of your head that you like did you
look up
i'm so excited
yeah harry potter they mentioned that
yeah she does it in the first one and
the second one yeah this
actress well she's drama club yeah
i need to tell you something and she's
like what and i'm like i like girls what
do you guys do
i'm a makeup artist i am a cheerleader
i'm a high schooler i'm bisexual
i'm a harry potter and they have a lot
of stuff stay tuned for
odd one out hell yeah uh
they killed it jubilee did such a great
job on this
uh setting it all up and the edit was
great as well
kid your videos helped me through
depression feedback so cool
so cool but i didn't say that
pewdiepie's among us skills are really
shining here
thank you when pewdiepie has the lowest
quality camera of ever
yeah okay all right yeah here it is i've
never seen the less toxic group of
individuals on you believe this brother
just holds them
pewdiepie types yo brandon we know it's
sambuda matt well it was tyler but yeah
maybe picking london was too obvious
maybe picking alex was too obvious
damn it technically i didn't pick my
name but i can't blame you but
either yeah shout out to all uh all the
participants as well you guys were
fantastic
super fun video loved it go subscribe to
you building show them support
tell them pewdiepie sent you oh shout
out to paulo as well
great guy all right that's it oh we got
new merch
110 million club here's me wearing it
here's me not flexing at all here's the
hoodie
very cool and here's the zero death
hoodie check it out
link in the description that's it bro
fish
[Music]
feeling lonely with all the crew and you
can't go to the
just download it for free for freebies
oh yeah gonna go with it
i got something for you
[Music]
[Applause]
you